assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato brothers and sisters you're
here with brother Ali Dawa and brother
Musa at none
welcome to the Dawa mobile chat show
what's this all about and why do we
start it okay basically we am also in
the car just like this
and basically we just for talk so you
know what most of our time is in the car
of the copy you guys were always around
London we go like you know Manchester in
different kind of locations so for why
don't use this opportunity to basically
talk about our stuff and stuff in
general regarding advice for the
brothers and sisters like all kind of
issues or whatever it be and also gonna
have different guest on the show that
Musa at 9:00 it's died I've never seen
after running BRE in Hampton sources
Imran Hussein from IRR in run a bit
monster mr. Dawa man or you're all kind
of various people that we're going to
talk about various topics and also I
really want to interact with you guys
with the show I'm gonna do so basically
we will be giving shoutouts to certain
individuals so all you have to do is
comment your name below the video and
say brother can you give me a shout-out
and shadowy to do that not only that you
can ask questions to us you can say you
know what I want to know this about
brother Musa or I know this about
yourself or can you answer this question
anything you want just put it on the
comments below on the video and shadow
would answer it then you want to add
more and that's it man as brother Ali
mentioned you know we're busy all the
time
and you know this is like a perfect
scenario and situation where we can you
know express what we think about you
know life in general about advice and
inshallah you know we can give it to you
guys while we're on the move so it's
excellent and it's an excellent
initiative and each other I'll go well
man yeah and if there's anything we
basically to improve on or you think you
know what you can do this better or any
anything regarding the videos glad ND
and firstly i really forgot about is a I
will attack every single one of you may
Allah sponsors mercy and blessing be
upon you off I hoping us raise for this
camera and I guarantee will be you'll be
big beneficial for the people that are
watching and also brother moose is going
to start a new show called Nym advice
which will be using this cameras we also
look the reward will be in shuttle shed
with that as well and show you guys will
get a reward I really want to thank you
guys obviously we get critics and stuff
like that but you guys are beside
and you suppose because you believe in
us and we really respect that without
first with the permission of Allah o
Allah and then you guys won't be where
we are today
so everyone thank you guys and each
other looking forward to the next show
and we'll see that all right welcome
Salaam